I'm getting firing is more important
than hiring it's the single reason most
people don't scale fast they get
crippled by thinking they're the one
miracle person on earth that can vet
people better than anybody and I think I
have the best people skills of all time
and even though I'm not great at it
because it's just a crapshoot more than
people want to admit there's too many
variables moments in time this person
was always great but yesterday he
started having an affair like there's
just a million variables I know that's a
funny one but like I'm you know like
everything can happen in life yeah the
second kid [ __ ] up his vibe she
doesn't like her husband anymore I'm
going very rogue like but like no like
you know like she got into yoga and now
that takes up her ties like she really
man I want to be healthy
he took up you're like there's a million
things that happened feels a different
person was yesterday yes so that's what
people don't understand you know so
that's why you can't say this guy rocked
it at [ __ ] guilt group and fear
rocket for you maybe he liked that the
space better maybe storage is boring so
she liked you know like her number two
so much and that was actually the person
that was there's just too many variables
so hey I think you know you're you're
you're you from what I know about you
like I think we have some similarities
that I would tell you that you go on
your intuition and then you you ask you
ask the people you think are better at
the black and white upfront this guy you
take that recommendation
you kind of take their word for it for
75% you go with your intuition on top of
that you go here's what I would tell you
this is what I did not do in my younger
years that may help you it was probably
the best thing I did started doing when
you meet these people you tell them what
you care about and then you tell them
they will get fired if they don't
deliver on that thing so I think the
thing that really changed my career was
I started telling people I and it was
very simple I was like look you may be
the best
this thing you may be the best data
scientists on earth you may be the best
creative director you may have the best
nose for early-stage startups but if you
do not play nice with the other boys and
girls because that's the thing I care
about
and that doesn't need to be your thing
but it's really deeply important to me
because any tension takes up my time
like I hate conflict and negativity so
much it takes up my time like I even I'm
such a guy in the offense but I have to
go on a defense when there's conflict
cuz that's what takes up my time thus
that's the thing that will like if
you're taking up my time you're
vulnerable
I said Morgan Kennedy if we are not the
category winner Randy Randy one of the
Kleenex is a very right so I think the
thing that the way through its - I think
that might be a little - like for me
when I go tactical I'm like look if the
people underneath you parallel to you
there if they don't like you and that's
what they're saying that's such a lofty
thing that would be like hey instead to
my CEO and CFO and the chief creative
officer I didn't say what I want which
is I want this to be the greatest
marketing machine of all time - lafi
yeah
- ambiguous - gray - up there a little
bit more in the dirt got it like you
need to understand first find it not one
number
when they're audited is a problem like
you need to be a math like have it down
like if I walk by you and go like what's
the churn you need to know what at the
top of your head not let me get my three
people to get me a report to tell you
three weeks later if that's what you
care about you may not I don't know
everybody is different but I would be
very detailed upfront and let them know
it's a deal breaker because then people
opt themselves out if they believe you
most people won't believe you but if it
even saves you three candidates out of
ten that's good so that's one thing what
do you and then the other thing is
there's no difference between building
from zero to 165 then there is from 155
to a thousand it's what's in front of
you that's the single most important
time and then the other thing that I
think is very important is for me and I
don't know if this works for you but I
doubt you've gotten this big this - lack
of micromanagement
yeah similar make well and all your time
of what you're best at and then
recognize everybody else doing a seven
or an eight or 6.5 of your in your brain
that you can do a 10 because that's the
way scale yeah those are scenes that
really matter and I was high it comes
down to firing yeah it's benefiting is
something important about the women
right like that's how a lot like that's
it so next thing the 45 people that work
in corporate yeah you need to have a
real relationship with them absolutely
do great
every single one makes me so happy it's
huge it's harder to have a relationship
with it's a different relationship
because with drivers I live in saw the
jam on the way out stuff I got at 23rd
Street and I saw Chuck and I walked up
and the person says that's the owner of
the company the owner of the company is
when you want to pizzeria the dry
cleaners that Fiona I don't feel like
the owner I'm the chief executive
officer I have a position in the company
as a corporation but I'm not the owner
Mark Suster has equity is well because
you have equity in the company
you're just as much an owner in this
companies I am well I wish if you're
willing to give me that equity I'm
interested um I understand I understand
so it's a different relationship because
this is in their mind they literally
call me sir like because I'm the owner
and I try to I'm like no you understand
it's a different relationship that I
have and I think what we can do on that
side is create the best job in the
entire Moving storage category
categorically that don't we get the best
sound so cool that to me the way my
brain filters it is romantic and nice
and I like it next the 45 people the 17
people that really run your company with
you the seven you need to know
everything you need to have dinner with
them
you need to give a [ __ ] you need to weep
the biggest mistake people make is not
having real relationships tough
conversations easy ones having the
ability to have years like a years a
year where it's not black and white then
good years of black it like the only way
your glue is relationship I would I
would tell you without a doubt because I
don't think anybody does enough even me
how many people you do truly believe are
the keiki [ __ ] people that drive the
business for real for real yeah five
seven eleven six Felton I'm dying and
another one
good I'm dying to know what your
relationship with those six people is
and whoever you have the least
relationship with if that breakfast and
did it like all in that's a big big
piece of advice that I think people are
going to lose on highly recommend it it
will work like on their terms how they
like it
dinner breakfast the ballgame dinner
with the wives dinner with the
girlfriends like it's a big deal and
we're I'm noticing that and so that's
what I would that's the piece of ice I
give you I think that's why we're
winning yeah because our competitive set
doesn't care about their people just
they don't and and I think also when
times are tough you know macroeconomic
climates you see if you struggle to
raise the round you want because you
project there that would be there like
you know when the world gets tough
upfront LPS don't like back out and give
them up in them you know like you just
never know the things that seem the most
tried and true you know Bear Stearns
right like the American economy like it
there's nothing off limits when running
a business you know what I mean
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]